Sam,
>> what happened?
>> Hello.
>> Yes. Hello. I can hear the background.
GI, you got to silence it.
>> Okay, let me go to a quiet location.
>> Hello, Darkness, my old friend.
>> So,
you know, um,
>> what made you call me again?
>> Well, because
well, from time to time I I do call you,
right?
>> Yeah, I know. But it's been a while. So,
how what like what made you call today?
What happened? But go ahead, Lo. Yeah,
>> I mean I I get your notifications,
right? So, I'll see when you're online.
So, YouTube will be like, "Hey, Sam is
live." So,
>> whenever I feel like it, I'll be like,
"You know what? I'll give him a call.
See what the deal is."
>> But, um, I did speak to like,
>> look, I I, uh,
>> who' you speak to?
>> CP. So I mean the thing is
>> today you know like suppose Islam became
became garbage. Suppose it did.
>> Yeah. you know, and and and and and the
thing is about you guys is that you you
it's it's you guys that were the ones
that made me angry to the point where
it's like you're attacking my faith
because I used to be so sure about it
and I used to be so, you know, like I
was just like, how could they do this?
You know, it's like how could they do
this? Like they they it it makes your
mind go in circles and and at the end of
the day, it is what it is. Okay, you got
you guys have brought your arguments.
I've evaluated it. It is what it is. Um,
but I still think that there's a lot of
good things in Islam. Maybe some of the
technical points you guys bring up make
sense. But how can you prove that
Christianity is true? I mean,
>> yeah. Well, that's very easy.
>> How can you prove it?
>> Yeah. Because of here's the argument for
the truth of Christianity.
>> What is the argument? prophecies,
predictions in the Old Testament
pointing to Messiah coming, dying and
rising from the dead and the historical
Jesus
resurrecting from the dead as a fact of
history witnessed.
>> No, the Old Testament doesn't doesn't
talk about this.
>> Yes, it does. So, you're telling me
>> about a prophet that will come from the
children of Israel?
>> Isaiah 53.
>> But it says prophet.
>> No, it doesn't. It says Isaiah 53, a
servant who will be killed for your sins
and will be raised to dwell and prosper.
>> I'm just going to make a note of that
for my own reference real quick.
>> Sure. So, I'm telling you the proof of
Christianity. The proof is predictions
made in the Old Testament centuries
before the Messiah and Jesus showing up
in history which you believe claiming to
be that Messiah dying like the prophet
said he'd die rising on the dead and
eyewitnesses.
>> So if he is the Messiah, why would the
Jews turn against him?
>> Well, because they were stubborn and
refused to accept God's revelation. Not
all Jews.
>> A bunch of arrogant Jews. Not not all
Jews though because his f first
followers were Jews.
>> Jews are arrogant.
>> If you want to say that, that's up to
you, man. So, what do you want me to
tell you?
>> That's been my experience with them.
>> Okay. Well, I that's if you want, you're
comfortable publicly on the record
saying they're arrogant. That's up to
you. But not all Jews Not all Jews
rejected Jesus. And none of them
believed in Jesus.
>> What?
>> Go ahead. What do you mean? Go ahead. I
don't know if you even heard what the
argument was. What was the argument for
the person?
>> Isaiah 53 prophesied.
>> You want me to read it for you?
>> Jesus.
>> Go.
>> Okay. I'm going to read it for you and
you tell me who does this sound like.
Okay. I'm going to read it. Isaiah 53.
Let me get it. Hold on. Let me get it
up. I want to read it for you. One
second, buddy. Oeline. All right. Here
you go.
>> Are you tired? You sound tired.
>> No, no, no. Don't worry about me. I'm
I'm always tired. I'm just tired of
living. All right. Anyway, are you
ready?
I want to read it. Don't interrupt me
because you got to hear it so you can
understand. Are you ready, Kendall?
>> Okay. This is written about 700 years
before the birth of Jesus. It's in the
Hebrew Bible. A copy of this, the
original. We have found a copy of this
book written around 125 years before
Jesus was born from Mary in the Dead Sea
Scrolls. So, we know it's before Jesus.
All right. Let me read it. Who has
believed our report? And to whom has the
arm of the Lord been revealed? For he
shall grow up before him as a tender
plant and as a root out of dry ground.
He has no form or beauty cleanliness.
And when we see him, there is no beauty
that we should desire him. He is
despised and rejected by men, a man of
sorrows and acquainted with grief. And
we hid as it were our faces from him
being ashamed of him. He was despised.
He was hated and we did not esteem him.
We did not respect him. Surely he has
carried our griefs
and carried our sorrows. And we esteemed
him stricken. We considered that he was
being
struck down, smitten by God and
afflicted. That's what we thought. But
he was wounded for our transgressions.
He was bruised. He was pre pierced,
crushed for our iniquities.
The discipline, the chastening, the
chastisement that brought us peace, he
took it. He took the chastisement
that we deserve so we could be at peace.
And by his stripes, we are healed. All
we like sheep have gone astray. We have
turned everyone to his own way. And the
Lord has put on him the sin of us all.
He carried all our sins. He was
oppressed and he was afflicted. Yet he
opened not his mouth. He was led as a
lamb to the slaughter
and as a sheep before its sheer is
silent. He did not open his mouth. He
was taken
>> from prison. You don't let me finish.
And from judgment. And who can declare
his generation? He was cut off from the
land of the living. Cut off meaning put
to death. Now watch. For the sins,
transgressions of my people. He was
struck down. And they made his grave. So
he's killed. Now they're going to bury
him with the wicked, but with the rich
at his death. Because he had done no
violence, nor was any deceit in his
mouth. Yet it pleased the Lord to bruise
him. He was put to grief. And when you
make your soul an offering for sin, he
then shall see seed, and his days will
be extended,
and the pleasure of the Lord shall
prosper in his hand, and he shall see
the fruit of his soul, the labor of his
pain, and he'll be happy. By his
knowledge, by his personal experience
with suffering, my righteous servant
will make many righteous. He will bear
their sins. Therefore, I will divide him
a portion with the grape. He shall
divide the spoil with the strong because
he poured out his life unto death. He
died and he was numbered with
transgressors and he bore the sin of
many and made intercession for the
transgressors. Who is this?
>> Well, so I'll I'll I'll tell you how I
understand it. I mean it it it it
looks like it
>> looks like
>> So this was in the Dead Sea Scrolls.
>> Yes. Like what though? Looks like what?
I didn't get it.
>> I mean it it
>> what?
>> I understand what it's saying.
>> Okay. If you I didn't tell you this was
from the Old Testament. You know this
would be Jesus, right?
This is Isaiah, right?
>> So 700 years before Jesus was born,
Isaiah describes Jesus being killed for
our sins and then seeing life again and
reigning.
>> Okay. So I mean this kind of sounds like
Jesus's story.
>> Yeah, exactly. 700 years before he was
born.
>> But is it authentic? How can it not be
authentic when we have a copy of it
that's before Jesus 125 years before
Jesus was born? The Dead Sea Scrolls.
Look at it. You want me to send you the
link here? You'll see a copy of it here.
Hold on. All right. Let me get it for
you. All right. Copy Isaiah 53 Dead Sea
Scrolls. Here it is. I'm going to send
you the link for the image. All right.
All right. Here it is.
Let me find it for you.
There's only two issues that I'm trying
to reconcile. What is it?
>> It's just what the academic scholars
say. And then the question in my mind is
why, you know, God would change
change his his his nature completely.
>> I don't know what you mean change his
nature completely. I just sent you the
link. Open up. You'll see the images.
>> No. Well, what I what I mean by that is
is you know the way the command the
commands that uh that are given in the
Old Testament and the things that are
done in the Old Testament and the way
the Jews believe in God in the Old
Testament becomes very different. Well,
because circumstances change.
>> Well, obviously when the Jews in the
time of Jesus flourished,
>> they were no longer in control of the
land. They no longer had kings ruling
over them. They had the Romans
oppressing them and controlling them.
Obviously, God in his mercy and love
will take the circumstances and
situation of his p people into
consideration. How are they going to be
able to live much of the Old Testament
when they're no longer the rulers of the
land? They no longer have kings. It's
pagans who are now ruling over them and
oppressing them. It'd be similar to
Muslims who are here. I'll give you
example. The Palestinians, don't you
complain that the Israelis came and took
the land, now you can't live the way you
want. You live under their tyranny.
>> Right?
>> Okay. So God in his mercy and love takes
that into consideration. My people are
now experiencing new difficulties, new
circumstances.
So that means I'm going to meet them
where they're at and I'm going to show
them a better way to help them in their
current situation because now that the
temple is destroyed, there are no
priests. How they going to keep much of
the Old Testament? Because much of the
Old Testament has to do with the temple,
the priests, sacrifices, and how to tend
the land. None of which is possible
because the Jews were scattered for over
1900 years before they returned to
Israel. Until this day, they don't have
a temple. So, how are they going to
follow the Torah the way it was revealed
originally?
>> And you don't Okay. And but at the same
time, you don't believe that you know
that the Bible is the direct words of
God.
>> Uh you mean that it's God dictating? No.
Because God has human authors expressing
>> no like the exact spoken word like
>> I'm trying to explain to you how can
that be when God is inspiring human
authors to write down what God wants to
be written down in human language
in human words.
This is the advantage of the Bible or
the Quran because if you tell me the
Quran is Allah's perfect word, then you
got a lot of verses that doesn't sound
like God speaking.